Light emitters can take whatever form you like since, ultimately, the effect of
a light is something computed in the vertex or fragment shading. That said,
there are a few different common forms of lights used in applications. The
simplest is called a directional light. This type of light is defined by just
that, a direction vector. A directional light is something like the sun. The
direction to the sun is essentially the same for every object on earth, and a
directional light is considered infinitely far away. In many modelers, such as
the 3JS editor here, the directional light will be shown as some local point
that you can move around. However, you're truly manipulating the direction, not
the location of the light. Since we often combine colors in various ways,
there's not necessarily an upper limit of 1.0 to a color channel. It all
depends. For example, if I want a clear the screen, I would want to use values
from zero to one. There's an upper limit of each channel's intensity, so values
larger than 1.0 are beyond the monitor's abilities. However, if I wanted to
make the light bright, I might set its intensity to 11. When the distance from
the light to the object and the object's color are taken into account, the
final color may well be within the zero to one range. In some systems, you can
even set the light intensity to a negative number, meaning the light is somehow
sucking photons from the surface. The light's color is just a number in an
equation after all. This is true for a material's color too, that it could be
set however you want, but we tend to leave material colors between zero and
one, thinking of them as reflectivities. These basic illumination equations are
not based on any physical unit, such as watts or lumens, but rather are set in
the zero to one range for our convenience.